bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 26
février bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition de votre journal de fin de
semaine voici les principaux sujets que
nous allons développer au cours de la
prochaine demi heure heller technologies
société d'ingénierie basé dans
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
se développe cette start up fondée en
2014 ne cesse de recruter
focus sur son activité l'union
départementale des élus socialistes et
républicains des yvelines se dote d'un
nouveau président jean claude husson
également maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines est l'invité
du journal nous parlerons de cette
structure mais également de ses sujets
d'inquiétude fusion des départements et
réforme territoriale porté par le
gouvernement comme chaque vendredi
retour aussi sur les faits importants de
l'actualité depuis le début de la
semaine disparition programmée du
bailleur social opievoy préparatifs du
salon de l'agriculture et 120e
anniversaire du centre météo de tram
économie donc pour débuter cette édition
avec un focus sur cette société fondée
par deux versaillais en 2014
heller technologie elle devrait recruter
dans les prochaines semaines une dizaine
de salariés visite donc de cette start
up en pleine expansion avec william l
bonjour je me permets de vous appeler
j'ai consulté votre cv sur le site de
l'apec est aujourd'hui vos compétences
m'intéresse à travers un projet que j'ai
avec un de mes clients ils souhaitent
pas une agence d'intérim mais bien une
société de conseil en ingénierie renault
airbus areva ou alstom les clients ce
sont eux et aujourd'hui ils passent tous
par hiver technologie pour embaucher des
ingénieurs sur des missions spécifiques
nous avons deux types d'intervention
soit
on positionne nos collaborateurs
elle est la technologie qui sont
principalement issus d'écoles
d'ingénieurs ou soit nous faisons une
recherche spécifique pour nos clients
afin de répondre parfaitement à leurs
besoins
les collaborateurs sont en réalité
directement employés en cdi par et leurs
technologies à la fin de leur mission
qui varie entre 6 et 18 mois la société
des envies racheter un autre client
on est poussé par nos clients à faire
une forte croissance on est poussé par
nos collaborateurs à faire une forte
croissance c'est pour ça qu'en fait en
première année on est passé de 0 à 50
collaborateurs et lacan en deuxième
année
on pense que notre atterrissage on sera
environ une centaine de collaborateurs
dans les bureaux de l air technologie à
versailles les recruteurs se
répartissent les différents secteurs
d'activité aéronautique spatial défense
énergie ou industrie automobile et
ferroviaire
la société a su s'imposer sur un marché
très concurrentiel avec un chiffre
d'affaires prévisionnel de 6 millions
d'euros pour 2016 et l'objectif
d'atteindre les 10 millions en 2017
nous poursuivons ce journal avec un
sujet de solidarité à présent un projet
développé attrape une semaine d'efforts
pour financer son projet c'est son nom
permet aux jeunes en partenariat avec
elle les bailleurs de la ville de
participer à des chantiers de remise en
peinture lors de vacances
une première expérience professionnelle
qui leur permet aussi d'être rémunéré
william l les flèches au cannet est
repassé et qui on les a eus et le point
on n'y a pas eu d'accord dont claude
plessis
ils ont entre 16 et 25 ans et pour
certains c'est une première expérience
de travail
l'opération une semaine pour financer
son projet permet à des jeunes
trappistes de travailler pendant cinq
jours soit 25 heures pour un salaire
d'environ 200 euros
le fait de pouvoir présenter des projets
c'est une première approche du monde du
travail donc c'est une manière de se
vendre
en général ils essaient de pouvoir
sortir différentes thématiques qui
sortent un peu de l'ordinaire et puis on
leur demande aussi un cv de façon à ce
que réellement il ya une logique à
savoir cv et motivation qui est vraiment
les premiers pas l'embauchent quoi
finalement
en partenariat avec la ville et les
bailleurs sociaux ce dispositif réparti
les jeunes sur plusieurs chantiers
cette semaine sensibilisation au tri des
déchets nour a 17 ans et elle avait déjà
participé à un chantier il y a deux ans
cette année elle s'est inscrite pour
financer ces équipements de boxe bon job
en fait c'est d'aller chez les personnes
et de sensibiliser sur le tri on demande
un peu s'ils font du tri si ces enfants
ok s'ils savent un peu parce qu'à
certains nous disent oui oui mais on
pose des petites questions pêche du
genre la bouteille dit il faut la mettre
dans quel bac le bal jeunes ou vieux ray
comme c'est de savoir un peu parlé avec
eux d'avoir un peu de relations aussi
avec son équipe n'aura va organiser son
après midi en se répartissant les
appartements aujourd'hui on fait voir si
j'ai bayer valophis arepa et de la
mairie trappe on fait une action pour
l'association autre hic ça va ça va
créer votre défi muni de son flyer la
jeune fille écoute expliqué fourni
prospectus et sacs de tri avant de
continuer sa tournée ce 5e déjà un
salaire facilite ne pas prendre d'autres
sacs quand ils descendent pour pour
descendre leurs poubelles de tout est
écrit sur le sec
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre dedans tout
ça c'est à mettre dans la poubelle jaune
et ses pratiques pour en 2016 ce sont
120 jeunes qui participeront à ce
programme qui s'étale sur quatre
semaines jusqu'au mois de mai une
réussite puisque depuis 2011 330 jeunes
ont pu profiter de ce dispositif
on passe à l'entretien du vendredi
bonjour jean claude husson bon jeu venu
en plateau vous êtes le président de
l'uds dsr y c'est l'union départementale
des élus socialistes et républicains des
yvelines également maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines vous venez de
prendre vos fonctions en tant que
président de cette union socialiste
qu'elle expliquait nous un peu la
finalité les objectifs de cette
structure l'objet c'est tout simplement
de rassembler les élus du département et
de les faire travailler ensemble de
d'organiser des formations aussi
notamment sur le territoire vous avez
des élus minoritaires qui sont un peu
isolés dont ils ont besoin aussi de
comprendre les problématiques de voir
comment travaillent les autres élus
quelles sont les problématiques on peut
rencontrer sur le terrain donc c'est un
lieu des changes
c'est à la marge élus de la fédération
socialiste voilà ça rassemble des élus
de la réunion sur les élus cette fois ci
c'est pas une scission au sein d un pas
du tout ça comme il ya beaucoup de
structures c'est pour que les choses
soient déçus par les internes
assemblement d'élus qui partagent des
expériences pour aiguiller sur les
responsabilités des uns des autres vous
le disais c'est particulier aussi
peut-être au territoire et de l'inra
mais il ya beaucoup d'élus minoritaire
aussi
étant donné les résultats des dernières
élections sur le sur le département la
droite et est assez majoritaire
largement majoritaire dans beaucoup de
communes comment il se débrouille
justement ces élus quelles sont les
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent ceux qui
sont en position minoritaire il ya
plusieurs d'abord dans leur commune
c'est sans doute l'isolément donc c'est
important de rencontrer d'autres usines
pour partager on a une nouvelle
problématique qui vient c'est celle des
intercommunalités comment se positionner
au sein d'une intercommunalité quand on
vous avez d'un côté des élus
minoritaires sur leur commune et
d'autres qui gère des communes et qui
n'ont pas nécessairement les mêmes
problématiques donc c'est c'est quelque
chose qui vient qui est nouveau
notamment avec cette réorganisation
territoriale et auquel on doit
travailler ça fait partie du rôle de
l'idée three de de clarifier les modes
de fonctionnement justement sur cette
réorganisation territoriale et aussi
cette question éventuellement d'une
fusion des départements alors
département des yvelines avec le
département des hauts-de-seine 78 92 qui
se rapproche on va leur préciser aussi
il n'ya pas le d'élus de gauche au sein
du conseil départemental des yvelines
la démocratie
c'est le jeu a exclu de l'assemblée sur
ce mandat les élus de gauche
il ya aussi des interrogations qui se
pose que vous vous posez puisque le
rapprochement est enclenchée c'est en
cours et vous n'êtes pas forcément
favorable en tout cas la difficulté sur
cette fusion c'est d'abord qu'elle a pas
été annoncée elle ne serait ce que
pendant les élections de l'année
dernière une personne ne l'avait sur le
programme donc c est quand même assez
assez curieux de de proposer maintenant
cette fusion et puis il ya eu une
absence de concertation puisque même les
conseillers départementaux certains ont
découvert ça dans leur enveloppe
semaines avant de venir en conseil
départemental donc un manque de caen
cette concertation qui est un peu le
même mode de fonctionnement que qui a
prévalu aux fermetures des pmi par
exemple ouais j'ai une veine pmi dans ma
commune on a découvert un jour
maternelle et infantile avait organisé
dans le département
exactement on a trouvé un jour un
écriteau sur la porte 10 ans est fermée
aller à rambouillet c'est des méthodes
quand même qu'ils sont particulièrement
curieuse j'espère que cela va va changer
c'est une des difficultés que le conseil
départemental doit travailler c'est que
l'absence d'opposant fake et son seul
nom pas de contradicteur et donc c'est
encore plus difficile d'assurer quand
même un rôle démocratique donc il faut
qu'il soit prudent avec ça en tout cas
lui dise riz sera attentive à ce que le
fonctionnement démocratique du
département soit conservé et si on
s'arrête juste quelques instants encore
sur cette question de rapprochement des
départements
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète dans l'idée
de teyjat pas fusionner mais rapprocher
deux entités de département l'objectif
annoncé c'est tout simplement de faire
des économies de mutualiser les moyens
oui tout à fait mutualiser les moyens
lorsque le département des yvelines est
un des départements les plus peuplés que
c'est aussi l'un des départements les
plus riches de france
sur une superficie qui est la plus
petite c'est un département en
superficie les plus petits de france on
se demande ce qui peut encore être
optimisé
ça c'est une vraie question là
l'optimisation elle passe surtout par la
recherche des économies en interne
plutôt que d'être c'est en étant plus
gros que plus gros qu on peut faire des
économies c'est faux ou alors dans ce
cas on fait une grande commune qui
s'appelle la france et on va faire de
supers économie on voit bien que c'est
faux
il faut regarder en interne au sein du
conseil départemental et de son
fonctionnement comment on peut faire des
économies
les aigles celui qui fait le plus
d'économies à mon avis c'est le maire de
village parce que lui il est au courant
de tout il sait ce qu'il a commandés
pourquoi si ça a bien été réalisés et si
peu payé la facture
plus vous montez sur des structures plus
importantes plus c'est difficile parce
que les travaux sont sectorisé par
service le comptable lui il a une
facture épais il a un service et andy
c'est fait ils regardent pas dans le
détail et donc il faut être en capacité
de regarder dans le détail le
fonctionnement parce qu'il ya
certainement des économies à faire sans
doute 10% d'économies à faire et ça
c'est un travail de détails il suffit
pas de dire on va faire des économies en
supprimant des pmi on va faire des
économies en supprimant 5 euros 50 par
jour par berceau pour les crèches
ça c'est des économies le comptable il
faut faire des économies d' analyse de
réels dégâts
néanmoins il ya des vraies économies à
réaliser elles sont encore plus
importantes que les 5 euros 50 dont vous
parlez parce qu'il ya une baisse des
dotations de l'état et ça monte très
haut notamment pour les collectivités
comme le département des sas et toutes
les collectivités qui participent au
raid ray au redressement des finances de
la france
encore à 60 plus de 70 milliards de
déficit budgétaire c'est-à-dire
interdépartement perco jusqu'à 80% de sa
dotation
est ce que c'est normal que le
département l'un des départements les
plus riches de france ont attiré la
manche du pays pour avoir de l'aide on
voudrait pièces de notation a justifié à
aujourd'hui la question se pose je veux
dire il y à une répartition sur le
territoire et notamment celle d'un
territoire rural donc je comprends aussi
la problématique des départements ruraux
jeudi
je défends aussi la problématique du sud
divine et de l'ouest des yvelines qui
sont départis rurales du département
quand aujourd'hui sur le territoire de
des yvelines on a peut-être six ou sept
conseillers départementaux qui
représente la partie rurale cr plus de
70% de notre territoire
sur 42 élus demain ses six ou sept vont
être au milieu de 88 élus qui sont
essentiellement urbain alors aucun point
on passera d'une représentation de 15 %
des conseillers départementaux a
peut-être puis % fins il n'y aura plus
aucun poids pour le secteur rural
aujourd'hui à une réorganisation
nécessaire en tout cas la réorganisation
et qu'elle se fait en insert le
département est un gros département qui
est riche et donc ça se regarde dans le
détail comme le fait le maire de petit
village c'est regarder comment on
dépense réellement et comment on peut
optimiser c'est un travail
de détail et qui se regarde à la loupe
et c'est aussi un message que vous
faites passer au sein des élus qu'ils
soient majoritaires ou minoritaires de
dents au sein de l'association accepte
l'union départementale des élus
socialistes et républicains des yvelines
dont vous êtes le nouveau président va
aussi profiter de votre présence alors
ce n'est pas fait exprès de lui avant et
je sais que vous l'avez aperçu c'est la
une du parisien de ce matin le ps
passera-t-il l'hiver je vous pose la
question
moi je laisse ce qui est évident
socialise je l'espère je suis moi j'ai
voté au dernier congrès pour la motion
intermédiaire entre la il a baissé entre
celles qui coince soutient le
gouvernement et celle des frondeurs
parce que il faut accompagner tout en
étant critiqué dit réellement ce qu'on
pense aujourd'hui quand je vous me
demandiez si j'intervenais beaucoup je
disais très peu parce que je mets mes
filles des réseaux sociaux il ya des
phrases toutes faites qui sont émises il
faut quand même un petit peu plus de
profondeur dans l'analyse de l'action la
réforme territoriale je l'expliqué dans
ma commune
ça me prend un certain temps pour
expliquer pourquoi on fait tout ça je
les fais aux voeux aux voeux du maire au
mois de janvier c'est pour les enfants
se poiler petits-enfants c'est pour
réduire les déficits et ne plus
continuer ce qu'on fait depuis le début
des années 70 c'est à dire emprunter
pour assurer leur seul essai sera sinon
suivante qui rembourse ça fait ce texte
sortir de l'impasse
le titre de cette tribune publiée par un
martine aubry dans le monde c'était le
25 février vous l'approuvez ce texte
vous le comprenez où c'est malvenu par
17 déstabilise aussi peut-être un peu
l'action du gouvernement
ça fait partie du débat fut toujours
existé sa virulence à ces violons mais
si on restera t-il les idéaux du social
est simple lorsqu'on aura jour après
jour ça paie ses principes et ses
fondements il y en a qui sont venus y en
a qui sont contre et y compris dans ma
propre section à saint-arnoult ça fait
partie du débat et on va en débattre
vous allez en débats très longs mois
j'espère qu'il y aura des primaires
alors voilà c'est la question que
j'allais vous poser pour conclure comme
ça vous y avaient déjà répondu la
semaine prochaine à votre place pour
réagir à tous ces sujets benoît hamon
députés socialistes également également
conseiller régional d'île de france
merci à vous d'être venu en place un
logiciel que vous êtes aussi le maire de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines merci
seconde partie de ce journal nous
passons à l'essentiel de l'actualité de
la semaine le zapping des sujets
développés depuis lundi pourquoi ma
candidature et pourquoi initiative
et bien simplement parce que
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
notre université est d'une certaine
manière en dormance il y as d'une d'un
côté l'université paris saclay dont nous
sommes membres fondateurs et puis il y
as d'un autre côté le département des
yvelines avec son monde économique ce
monde social
ça fait les deux polarités de
l'université il faut que ses adversaires
saint-quentin soit initiatrice soit
force de propositions voire même un peu
et guillon dans paris saclay pour que
paris saclay tourner son regard vers
nous et puis il faut que nous
développions que nous renforcions que
nous redynamise ion les partenariats
avec le monde économique
il y a évidemment trop de réglementation
ce qui empêche les activités de se
déployer dans tous les domaines c'est
vrai pour les familles pour les
collectivités territoriales pour les
entreprises pour les associations pour
les commerces pour tout le monde et d'un
autre côté il y a un minimum de règles à
adopter sans lesquels encore une fois la
compétition n'est pas égal il faut tel
de soi donc il faut les deux assouplir
les règles et en même temps faire en
sorte que les règles une fois assoupli
s'applique pour tous ont pu constater qu
on a eu une baisse d'à peu près 25% de
nos attaques
et ça impacte directement nos
exploitations agricoles et aujourd'hui
on est on est vraiment dans la dans la
crise puisqu'on voit la fin je te
l'avais noté l'exemple d'un jeune
agriculteur qui s'étonne qu'ils
s'installaient sur une moyenne de 100
hectares en 2013
il va perdre 32 % de son revenu
disponible ces voix là et comme le
disait christophe vis-à-vis nous
nos voisins allemands on a un écart de
dead de l'ordre de 150 euros ha donc
c'est quand même très très important et
dimanche 21 février marisol touraine
ministre de la santé a annoncé vouloir
mettre en tablier en application une
augmentation forte et significative du
prix du tabac le plus vite possible
elle s'est même dit favorable à un
paquet à 10 euros tout en reconnaissant
que ce ne serait pas sous ce quinquennat
actuellement le prix moyen d'un paquet
de cigarettes est de 7 euros dans les
yvelines les professionnels craignent le
développement grandissant du marché
parallèle l'opievoy bientôt en passe de
disparaître le second plus gros bailleur
social de france est aujourd'hui victime
de la loi allure l'obligeant à être
rattachés à une collectivité locale
unique au 31 décembre 2016
problème valérie pécresse présidente de
la région ile de france a annoncé le 18
février dernier qu'elle ne reprendrait
pas la structure à sa charge
pourquoi pas se doter d'un outil 80
mille locataires et je comprends pas
d'un côté en favorise des regroupements
intercommunaux favorise des grosses
structures les hypers structure et une
hyper structures comme pouvait l'être
sopi voit on la casse le président de
l'ot pivois pierre bédier n'ayant pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet a
annoncé lors de ses voeux que la masse
salariale ne serait pas réduite les
vacances un droit pour tous et tout au
long de l'année
c'est le credo du secours populaire aux
clayes-sous-bois fatoumata sept ans
s'apprête à partir pour la première fois
aux sports d'hiver
alors au moment de faire la valise le
choix est difficile
un put en cassure par par exemple dans
la neige et ça s'est fait un peu beau je
suis plus content mais sauf que j'avais
que ça se passe bien on voit et pato
blessures
et de réunir sauce classe et un truc en
plus des sites fixes ouverts dans le
département trois collectes mobiles sont
organisées chaque année à elancourt une
façon d'attirer l'attention sur le
besoin mais aussi de permettre les dons
aux habitants qui ne peuvent se déplacer
si ça peut motiver certaines personnes
qui le font pas à le faire
c'est très bien moi après jeu dès que
j'ai l'occasion je donne et y lire vous
avez découvert l'histoire des signes de
météo france a traversé de son fondateur
aujourd'hui dans un second épisode nous
vous proposons de revenir sur
l'évolution technologique les prévisions
du centre qui fête ses 120 ans cette
année lola vous rentrez également dans
le band j'avais toujours par bach
derrière christophe rosso est l'une des
victimes de l'inondation du quartier de
la boissière à plaisir ce vendredi vers
7 heures du matin une rupture de
canalisation de 60 cm de diamètre à
proximité de l'école alain fournier à
entrer une submersion partielle du
secteur
l'incident a entraîné des dégâts chez
habitants après la représentation les
spectateurs se pressent dans les écuries
amateurs de chevaux novices ils viennent
parfois de très loin pour voir le
travail de bartabas g réserver mes
billets sur tours elle je suis arrivé
ici exclusivement pour ça alors si le
spectacle vous tente les écuyers leurs
montures offre chaque week-end de
représentation le samedi à 18h ou le
dimanche à 15 heures alors que les
vacances d'hiver se poursuivent près de
3 millions d'enfants ne partent jamais
chaque année en france avec copains de
vacances le secours populaire aide ses
enfants des familles défavorisées à
sortir de leur quartier 3 yvelinois ont
pris la direction et des pistes de ski
et des hautes-pyrénées cette semaine
c'est le cas de fatoumata aux
clayes-sous-bois écoutez son témoignage
les vacances un droit pour tous et tout
au long de l'année
c'est le credo du secours populaire aux
clayes-sous-bois fatoumata sept ans
s'apprête à partir pour la première fois
aux sports d'hiver
alors au moment de faire la valise le
choix est difficile
un put
au casino par exemple de la neige et ça
si il fait un peu mou je suis plus
content autres mais savent que j'avais
que ça se passe bien on voit et pato
blessures
mais est de réunir un saut ce cas c'est
un truc
la petite fille est déjà parti en
vacances cet été avec le secours
populaire
le billet de train est à la charge de
l'association et le reste du séjour à la
famille d'accueil pour sarhane sa maman
ses vacances loin des clayes-sous-bois
permettent un moment d'évasion mais
aussi de la responsabiliser quand elles
viennent
lt fait lui s'est elle fait elle fait
tout tout seul avant ça elle peut pas
faire ça moi aide pas d'homme unsa -
vraiment très près de pantin l'opération
copains des vacances donne surtout la
chance aux enfants des familles
défavorisées de se faire de nouveaux
amis
les bénévoles dont qui sont les premiers
à voir les enfants et elle elle est
ramenée au treasure retour donc je me
disent qu'à chaque fois les enfants sont
ravis qu'ils ont pu faire des activités
qui ne pouvaient pas forcément faire
chez eux à la maison on a également des
enfants qui ne veulent pas repartir qui
fait rester dans la famille d'accueil
8h27 direction tarbes ce lundi matin
pour fatou matin à la gare montparnasse
la séparation avec sa maman est
difficile mais dans dix jours elle
reviendra avec des souvenirs plein la
tête
racontera les copies
c'était des vacances l'été dernier car
mon enfant yvelinois ont pu profiter de
l'opération copains des vacances du
secours populaire
un mot du programme de nos confrères
radio sensations nos confrères vous
propose donc ce week-end un hebdo
politique avec sophie primas première
vice présidente de la communauté urbaine
du grand paris seine et oise en charge
de l'agriculture elle a également été
nommée secrétaire départemental des
républicains elle évoquera avec cas
nicolas kirillovitch ses mandats et
l'actualité de son parti écouter cet
extrait il est question et des récents
propos de laurent wauquiez aujourd'hui
la nationalité française c'est devenu à
l'auberge espagnole
c'était mi février des propos prononcés
par le numéro deux des républicains
vous me lancer parfaitement puisque
laurent wauquiez le numéro deux du parti
ait fait un discours très remarqué dans
des propos parfois très à droite je le
cite il ya un danger de délitement
culturelle et politique ce n'est pas la
france de s'adapter aux étrangers c'est
aux étrangers de s'adapter à la france
est ce que ce type de discours il faut
ça vous combien il faut l'affirmer le
confirmer ou alors cette stratégie un
peu à droite tout ça vous gêne vous moi
simplement parce que ça vous a amené à
la défaite présidentielle en 2012 moi ça
ne me gêne pas du tout de dire que la
france a un certain nombre de valeurs et
que ceux qui vivent et un délitement
culturel selon vous ils risquent de gala
il ya une peur de délitement culturel et
nous aussi dans la vallée de la seine
dans les milieux dans le milieu rural de
la vallée de la seine je peux vous dire
que c'est pas forcément le sentiment
d'abandon de la ruralité qui conduit au
vote du front national c'est espèce de
peur du délitement des valeurs et de la
culture française donc si on se cache
derrière son petit doigt on peut se dire
que c'est pas ça mais dans la réalité il
ya une peur des français dans quelques
instants juste après ce journal de 7,8
week end avec les idées sorties et
loisirs pour les prochains jours lundi
vous retrouverez florane parfait pour
l'actualité locale en direct à 18h
première rediffusion 19 heures voici
quelques-uns des reportages que nous
vous proposerons alors que la réforme de
l'examen du code de la route a été
présentée mi février est les
professionnels regrettent un manque de
concertation ils menacent de faire grève
ce lundi
le code de la route et les conditions
d'examen change pour les apprentis
conducteurs les moniteurs n'apprécie pas
les délais imposés la semaine
les femmes à magny les hameaux avec
cette année une thématique autour des
peuples nomades expositions ateliers
rencontres au programme des rendez vous
annoncés pour favoriser l'évasion vers
de nouveaux mondes à la découverte de
nouvelles cultures et puis le salon de
l'agriculture ouvre donc ce week end les
producteurs des yvelines seront bien
représentés
la brasserie de la vallée de chevreuse
ferme de green ou encore ferme de la
tramblais présent également le chef
briscoe dos du restaurant monument café
à versailles pour une démo culinaire dès
le lundi 29 février que pensez vous de
ce rendez vous annuel du monde agricole
c'est notre question du jour au micro de
william el est patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est formidable pour moi c'est
l'occasion de voir pour aller voir les
animaux enfin tout soit là et d'emmener
les enfants quoi et ben moi je trouve ça
très intéressant parce qu'en plus je
veux travailler dans le développement
durable donc moi ça m'intéresse mais je
ne sais pas si je vais y aller ça va
être probablement un une occasion pour
les agriculteurs de de dire peut-être
plus précisément ce qu'ils ont comme
problème c'est ce que j'espère pour eux
voici très bien parce que moi même j'y
vais alors s'il vous plaît tout surtout
les animaux les restos qui à j'aime bien
parce que c'est de la bonne bouffe
encore très bien c'est très très bien
mais je crois qu arabe l'ambiance est
allé à bas à deviner pourquoi avec les
agriculteurs qui sont pas vraiment
content pied hollande qui arrive c'est
sûr que va faire des jeux parce que ça
va faire mais nous reviendrons sur cette
actualité bien sûr en début de semaine
prochaine je vous souhaite un excellent
week end en suivant nos programmes bien
sûr à lundi